- Hey everybody it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is episode 309
of the Ask Gary Vee show,
and I'm excited to have
a wonderful entrepreneur
to take your questions,
so Instagram and Facebook,
start throwing in your
phone numbers with maybe
a hashtag or two or data point of like,
where your question is going,
to give Raghav some indicator,
but obviously as we get into this episode
more data will be thrown
out, and so you can
add on that, continuously put your numbers
in there, and we will
pick some for the call.
But this young lady has built
a very impressive resume
we met on the Today Show doing
some entrepreneurial stuff
and I will let Alli say hello.
So for the VaynerNation,
why don't you tell everybody
who you are, and what you do.
- So my name is Alli Webb,
and I founded a company
called Drybar.
I feel like there's a
lot of men in this room,
but for all the ladies out there,
we are a blow dry bar.
- [Gary] Actually it's only four to three.
This is actually the best
ratio I think we've normally
have ever had.
- You're right, you're right.
I'm looking at all the guys.
(laughing)
- [Gary] I'm pretty public
to the four to three ratio.
Go ahead!
- Good! I'm happy to hear that.
So yeah, we were the first,
we started ten years ago,
we have 125 locations across the country,
four thousand stylists.
- [Gary] When did you start?
- 2010.
- [Gary] And when you
say you were the first,
because I'm very aware of the movement,
or maybe it's just because I live in it.
- There was nothing
like it when I started.
- [Gary] Nothing.
- Nothing.
- [Gary] And so back to that,
and by the way real quick for
all the entrepreneurs there,
one of the biggest questions I get is,
people take so much emotion in inventing,
we're adding on to something
a little bit differently,
and then when there's
something successful,
there's fast followers, and
they get so upset about that
and I'm like look, that's
just market dynamics.
- Yeah. I mean, listen, I feel like,
to unpack that a little,
we didn't invent blowouts.
We just created a much
better experience around it,
and the advice I give...
- [Gary] And you went all in.
- And we just kinda changed the game,
and the advice I give entrepreneurs is
there may be something
out there that exists
that you love, you just
wish was done better.
And we created a much better
experience and price point,
and location around blowouts
that just did not exist.
You used to have to go
to a full service salon,
or a discount chain, and the
experience just wasn't great,
we were overpaying.
- [Gary] Am I wrong in this?
Wasn't it just one of the menu
items versus the core item?
- It was a menu item, and it
was also one that most stylists
didn't wanna do because
they wanted to use that hour
to do a haircut that you
could charge a lot more from,
they didn't want to do a
blowout which was less money.
And it's funny 'cause it
really harkens back to the day
of like our grandmothers, and
grandmothers generation where
they get their hair quaffed
and they wouldn't touch it
for like, a week.
We kinda modernized that behavior.
But, make no mistake, I did
not know, none of us knew,
my brother, Michael Landau's
my business partner, also bald.
Like, none of us knew
what was in front of us.
We didn't realize how
big this opportunity was.
I was gonna open one store in L.A.,
pick up my kids from preschool,
and that was gonna be my little life.
The fact that we like,
we so underestimated the demand.
- Let me give you a comp,
and then we'll go back
to the origin story.
For awhile now, about 20 months,
it's been running through
my head that like,
a french fries only
restaurant QSR would dominate.
You didn't invent french
fries, it was a side dish.
- Could you get like all
different flavors of french fries?
- Yeah, I'm really hot on
the whole concept of like,
the different ketchups
and mustards and salts,
but one core french fry.
So it's not like seven
different french fries,
my concept is, this crazy french
fry that everyone's about,
but it's the other things,
11 different ketchups,
the 11 different mayos,
the 11 different mustards,
and like the 13 different salts.
- [Alli] Interesting.
Except that french fries
are so bad for you!
But they're my weakness.
No but they're my weakness.
At least we have a healthy addition.
- [Gary] Alli, every single
person is getting brain cancer
from cell phones.
I don't need to hear people's
hot takes on french fries.
- [Alli] If that was like
the last thing I could eat,
it would be french fries.
I love french fries, so much.
So I am all in on this business.
Listen, do one thing and do it well!
That's my concept.
- That's right though.
- [Alli] I know that's
my french fry concept.
- So you started Drybar, 125 locations?
- [Alli] Yes.
- Franchise model?
Or all yours?
- They're predominately company owned,
I'd say we're about forty,
give or take, franchised
and the rest company owned.
Which you know, I could make
the argument either way,
there's great things about franchising
and there's not great
things about franchising.
Again, I could make the
argument either way.
- The reason you could make
an argument is now here we are
75 years later, and
both independently owned
corporate entities, and franchise models,
both have a place at the table.
- [Alli] They really do.
- The question is,
the mix of the two is
always a fascinating thing.
- And it's challenging
because it's a whole business,
finding and running a
franchise organization,
and there's a lot,
it's just a different set
of problems and issues.
But yeah, I think both are great.
- Where's the momentum in the company now?
- Product is a big push.
I mean we have almost
three thousand points
of distribution where
Nordstrom, Ulta, Sephora,
we're international with product,
we have a massive product
line from tools to
dry shampoos, to shampoos, you name it,
and what's great is if you
don't have access to Drybar
but you know and love Drybar,
which luckily most women
know about now, you can buy the product
and kinda replicate what
we're doing in the shops.
- Let's take this way way back.
What kind of girl were you growing up?
Were you entrepreneurial?
Were you like, sporty?
Were you like a nerd?
- Well, if you ask my parents,
they would have told you
I was such the underachiever.
My brother, Michael, who I
mentioned, total overachiever.
Micheal P. Keaton, which I
know you get that reference.
- Oh! Got it, like he was.
- [Alli] Remember from Family Ties?
- Yes, of course! Michael J. Fox!
- [Alli] Yes! I'm sure a
lot of people listening
don't know that reference, but
he was like the overachiever
of the family.
I was just, I've always been the...
- You were Mallory?
- I was like, I don't
totally remember her.
I remember her but not her character.
But I was kinda like,
it'll all work out and
I was never really worried about things.
- Where'd you grow up?
- [Alli] South Florida.
And, my hair is naturally curly.
So in South Florida it was very frizzy,
and I was always trying to figure out
how to get it straight.
I used to beg my mom to blowout my hair,
and that theme of hair and
trying to figure out my hair
kinda was always there and I
feel like the seed was planted
to do something in hair when I was a kid.
But then as I grew up and went
to high school and college,
well, I didn't really go to college
I went for like a minute,
all my friends knew what
they were gonna major in
and I really didn't know
and I was so lost and
confused out of high school
and I went to college for a second.
- Like a semester?
A half a semester?
- I think I maybe went for a year.
- 'Cause you're like, my hero.
- [Alli] I don't think I went
to like class all that much,
'cause I was like, I'm not
interested in anything.
- To make you feel comfortable
about this conversation,
this is my high school report card.
- Yeah I mean, we're about the same.
- Just notice that there's
only four A's, all in gym.
- Here's the greatest thing about
one of my favorite things about my life
is that I get asked to speak
at colleges all the time.
And every time they ask me I'm like,
you know I didn't actually
graduate from college,
I just wanna be upfront with that.
But that just goes to show you that,
not that I'm against college, I mean,
go to college, get an
education however you can,
but my parents were entrepreneurs,
so I grew up in a
entrepreneurial environment.
So I didn't know I was
getting that education.
- They didn't frown on...
- No 'cause my parents
didn't go to college either.
- But a lot of parents go the other way!
- But my parents were so cool,
chill, and they were like,
we just want you to do
what makes you happy.
They weren't so thrilled
when I made the decision
to go to beauty school.
- And is that what happened next?
- No, I went to,
technically, to Florida State
I just didn't go to class very often
'cause I grew up in Florida.
And then, I was like this is not for me,
I moved home, and then I
moved to New York City,
I thought I wanted to work in
fashion, and I worked for like
Nicole Miller and Cynthia Rowley,
this was like 25 years ago,
and then my brother and I started
Nicole Miller licensed stores in Boca,
which is where we grew up.
Realized didn't wanna do that,
and Michael and I were fighting so much,
and I was like, what the hell
am I gonna do with my life?
And I was like, you know the only thing
that I'm really passionate about is hair.
And I wanna learn how to do hair,
and I had worked at a
hair salon in high school,
where they would blow out my hair
and it was so magical to me.
So I said, I think I
should go to beauty school.
And my brother by the way
was like, you should go,
I can see you doing
editorial and fashion shows
in New York and I had this grand vision
of what I would do with hair,
where my parent's stores
were like little old lady clothing stores,
and like, retirement
communities in South Florida,
and they were like, you wanna
go work at beauty parlors?
And I was like, no, I wanna
do something amazing in hair!
Of course I didn't have the
vision of Drybar back then,
but I took the plunge,
went to beauty school,
again, to my parent's dismay.
- [Gary] And how did that go?
- They supported it and paid for it,
I feel like my mom was paying
off those loans forever
from beauty school,
'cause beauty school wasn't cheap either.
But literally the day I
walked in, I was like,
this is where I was meant to be.
I loved it, I fell in love
with it, I wanted to learn
everything I could learn.
It was the only thing I was
ever really passionate about,
which, again is such a good
example for people out there
who are like, they feel like
maybe the thing that they're
passionate about isn't like,
a great career option, you know?
- It's my singular thesis.
I really believe somebody
watching right now
who loves Star Trek or
Black Panther or Fortnite,
I really genuinely, or
making homemade jam,
I believe it.
And I believe it because of the internet.
I didn't believe it in 1963,
because there wasn't a system to go into,
like you can start a Black
Panther Instagram account,
and a podcast, and be active
on Black Panther forms
and Facebook groups, and
overtime get traction,
and something could happen.
That wasn't real.
- [Alli] We're so living
in the day where like,
anything can happen, anybody can make it
doing all sorts of stuff,
and I think I'm a great example of that.
- I apologize, but I think making it
is the biggest conversation
that entrepreneurs like
you and I who've made it
need to start helping the next generation,
because making it, I believe
if you love Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,
and you make 100 thousand a year,
because you have four sponsors:
Nickelodeon, the convention,
who knows, right?
And you make 100 thousand a year
hosting a TMNT, Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Podcast
and Instagram account, is
a much better life than
making 213k as an executive at Mckinsey
and being grossly unhappy,
and taking sleeping pills.
- Right! Because I mean, the
term making it is so relative.
- I'm so glad you're jumping
on this, it is probably,
I believe with anything
that works out for you,
I don't think it's a sense
of responsibility, but
I like giving back to
the game that put me on,
so I love entrepreneurship so much.
So much of who I am and what
I'm about is to give back
to the system.
But you have to update the system.
And we have to update what
being successful looks like,
it has to be happy, not rich.
It has to be.
- [Alli] I mean, I couldn't
agree with that more.
I mean, money was not
the driver ever for me.
I mean, money was like gravy.
It was like, oh, we're
gonna actually like,
make a living, doing this; amazing!
But, it was never about money.
And we didn't pay ourselves for years
when we first started Drybar.
It was never about money,
it's never been about money.
- Did you have a family when you started?
- Yes. I had my two sons,
and they were three and
five when I started,
they're 11 and 14 now.
- [Gary] Let's talk about
that for five seconds.
This is a subject matter that I've been
wanting to get more into.
- Well it's a particularly
interesting subject matter for me
because I'm going through a divorce.
But that's public.
- So, let's put that on
the side for a second.
- [Alli] So it's been quite a year for me!
- I respect that, and I'm
sorry to hear that, but
if you could indulge me,
I think one of the other
things that I like to do is
talk about what I know.
And I like to talk about
things I've lived through.
I will never have the luxury
of being an entrepreneurial mom.
- [Alli] No, that is never gonna happen.
- That's right, that is not in the cards.
- [Alli] Do you have kids though?
- I do.
- [Alli] Okay. How old are your kids?
- Nine and six, about.
- [Alli] Are you sure?
- Yeah, I am.
(laughing)
It's just they're both
already close to 11 and seven.
Nine and six, almost 11 and seven.
And I hate when people think
they understand something
that they'll never be.
I love when people are like,
I get you, and I'm like
no, you will never be an immigrant.
Like, I get you, nah you're
never gonna be a woman
or an African American or
a muslism during this time.
You can be sympathetic,
you can be empathetic,
but you'll never fully know.
So I want to take advantage of this.
'Cause I have a humongous audience,
I spend a lot of time engaging
with mother entrepreneurs,
but I never go all the way with my advice,
because I don't want to give
advice that isn't predicated
on things that I've tasted.
I have thoughts and theses, we all do.
But I wanna take advantage of this.
How much, if any, just right off the top,
a core question I'd love to
hear your perspective on.
How much, if any, guilt did you feel?
- [Alli] Tons. Always so much guilt.
- This is something I don't
believe a father will ever feel
anywhere in the same world as a mother.
- [Alli] Isn't that fucked up? Sorry.
- [Gary] I don't think so.
- Can I curse?
- [Gary] You can curse a lot.
I don't think it's fucked up.
- It is! It is because,
I'm on panels all the time,
and I speak all the time
and people always ask
that question to women, like
why don't you feel guilty
as a father when you don't
get to be home with your kids
as much as you could
'cause you're working?
- [Gary] 'Cause it's the
propaganda that we were fed.
- Yeah, that's what I mean!
- [Gary] That's what I mean.
- That's what I mean by it's fucked up.
- I'm curious about
this, I'm curious about
the process of giving birth.
Right? 'Cause I will never feel.
- [Alli] That is not fun.
- I'm making an assumption,
though I have no idea,
that there is some sort
of connection point
that is fundamentally different
when a human's in-fucking-side
of you, and then as a human,
versus, it was never inside of me.
And look, listen, I know
the way I feel about my mom
versus the way I feel about my dad.
I love them endlessly both,
there's some crazy fuckin'
real shit going on there
with mom that's just fuckin' real!
Like, I was of inside of her!
I even lived there for nine months!
That was my home!
- [Alli] I would make that
same joke to my ex-husband
and say like, they're
more mine than yours,
because they literally
came out of my body.
- I genuinelly actually believe that.
- [Alli] He didn't like that.
- Yeah, yeah, well,
especially given the context.
But, forget about, should
guys or not guys feel guilt,
back to the point; it hurts my soul,
'cause entrepreneurship is hard enough.
It is so difficult, it
is outrageously lonely.
It is outrageously lonely.
- [Alli] You have to have a
thick skin for it, no doubt.
And especially if you're a mom.
I mean, luckily,
my mom actually passed
away three years ago,
but she was there for
the beginning of Drybar,
and I had my life got
so turned upside down
in an amazing way, and I
had to travel all the time,
I had so much great
opportunities coming at me
and there was so much momentum
and excitement with Drybar,
and I just traveled tons.
And luckily my mom was there
so she was with my kids all the time,
and the guilt was massive
but had I had to leave her with a nanny,
my kids with a nanny,
that would have been...
God, I don't even know
if I could have done it
because my kids were so young.
My mom was there, it was
someone who was family
and loved them, and so I felt
very lucky in that regard.
But you know, listen.
That's not to say,
and I feel like the world
is so polarizing right now,
that's not to say if you have a nanny
and you're an entrepreneur
that's not okay too.
- I appreciate that.
- [Alli] That's okay too.
Whatever works for you.
- Look, I appreciate that.
And that's by the way
why I don't feel like,
some people are like, Gary!
Inevitably, to your point, polarizing
and everybody being so hardcore.
Gary, you should feel
guilt, no I shouldn't.
You don't know me.
Like, what about guys whose
mother has brain cancer when
they start their business?
Do you feel bad for them now?
My biggest thing is, you
know nothing about people.
- And you never know what's
going through somebody's...
- You can't imagine how
different any news now.
I'm going through a divorce.
Ten years ago, not that I
had any judgment on that,
it's funny that my brain would
think about it for a second,
what does that mean?
I have become numb because of
how polarizing the world is,
My hope is this is what's
actually going to happen
to everybody else, because
my life has been predicated
on doing actions a little
bit earlier than others,
and then figuring it out.
The level of judgment I have
on anybody at this point
is almost nonexistent.
I don't know what's going on!
I know what's going on
with Raghav and I at work!
- [Alli] To a certain point, right.
- He may share something with me,
Jason's shared some stuff on family stuff,
I've got some context on that,
I got a little something.
You don't know what's
going on with your spouse,
you don't know what's going
on with your children,
you don't know what's going on
with your parents all the way.
Nobody knows anybody else all the way.
- It's so true. I feel
like my mom always said,
it kinda relates,
if you have nothing nice
to say, say nothing.
- [Gary] I'm a buyer.
- Yeah, it's like you just don't know.
And I've always felt it,
you just don't know what
someone else is going through
at any given moment, so you're right.
I could not agree with
that statement more.
- And then all will go
through judgment moments.
Whether it's a divorce.
- [Alli] But keep 'em to yourself.
- But you know you're living it
through your most inner circle,
and you said, as it gets more public,
people have judgment who
are watching on Facebook
who have never heard of you!
Literally people are watching,
have never heard of you,
just heard you say it seven minutes ago,
and whether they typed it or thought it,
that's what humans do.
And that's fine, that's natural,
it's not like I don't have judgment,
but I think, much like
we started eating better,
much like we're now doing
better with our mental health.
- [Alli] Yeah, I've started
doing transcendental meditation
which is life changing by the way.
- Good for you, we'll go
over that in a minute.
- [Alli] This is going to be a
self help podcast, by the way!
- We need to start an
anti-judgment process and movement.
- [Alli] Yeah, I couldn't agree more.
- My brother's name is AJ, anti-judgment,
I kinda like this whole thing right now.
Please put your phone numbers in,
I wanna get some phone calls in.
What was the most ridiculously fun,
exciting moment in the early part?
Tell me one story, in 2010
you started, in 2011, 2012.
Give me some story of where
you were like, holy shit.
- Honestly there's so many.
- [Gary] I know, I know; I know girl!
- And it's a great question
which I don't think I've
really ever been asked that.
- And I'll tell you why I've
asked it, because I lived it.
I had so many moments, but
if I was reversed right now
I'd probably say, when
Conan had me on his show,
when I was doing my wine
blog, nobody from the internet
was really on T.V. yet,
besides Perez Hilton,
and it was like this huge moment
where my brother came from
college, and we watched it.
That was a moment where
we were like, holy shit.
Give me one holy shit moment.
Like did Oprah come in?
Did somebody mention a magazine?
Like, what is a holy shamolee?
- You know Carson Daly?
- [Gary] Very much so.
- And he had a radio show for a long time,
I don't know if he still does.
And this was really, I think in 2010,
within a few months of us starting.
Which reminds me of
Ryan Seacrest had a show
and Justin Bieber was
talking about Drybar.
I mean, there's so many of those moments!
But Ryan Seacrest, we were brand new,
maybe two or three months.
- [Gary] Carson Daly?
- I'm sorry, Carson Daly.
I started getting all these phone calls.
- And did you, to make
this story even better,
did you love Carson Daly on TRL?
- [Alli] Yes! Oh yeah, TRL,
yeah I knew him because of TRL.
- Everyday, cool people
follow me on Instagram.
- [Alli] And you're like, holy shit!
- Yes, but if it's somebody
I really gave a fuck about,
they may be far less famous,
like somebody may follow
me that's the most relevant
Netflix star right now,
and I'm like, cool!
But like, if a WWF
wrestler that I grew up,
like if Brutus The Barber
Beefcake followed me right now,
I'd loose my shit.
- [Alli] Really?
- He's there. Yeah, so go ahead.
- Carson Daly had a show,
and you would have thought we paid him
because he was on his computer
looking at our website,
talking about all our looks.
I think he even said something like,
oh look at Alli Webb, who's this hot girl?
Or something like that and I was like,
he just called me hot, he's
talking about my business.
- Now I know this story's,
that was the easiest tell of all time!
I love you for that, that is
really, definitely the reason.
If anybody ever calls me
hot, publicly, at scale,
it is the core thing I'm excited about.
Let's get very basic in here.
- I mean it doesn't suck to be
called hot on national radio,
- Especially if you love
TRL, like that's a yes.
- [Alli] And Carson Daly!
Which by the way I love him,
he's married and his wife
is awesome, she comes
to Drybar, nothing like that.
I just feel like I have to
qualify everything I say.
- [Gary] You had this seven years ago.
- It was ten years ago!
I don't even if he was married then.
Anyways, that was a big moment and then
very soon after that, Ryan Seacrest on
the Ryan Seacrest show
had Justin Bieber on,
they literally called Drybar,
and Justin was like,
hey it's Justin Bieber I want to make an
appointment to come to Drybar.
And the girl on the phone, god bless her,
she was like, I'm sorry
who, and he was like,
it's Justin Bieber and I'd
like to get the Bieber,
which is like when his
hair was a big thing,
remember when he had the hair?
This again was like ten years ago,
and she took it very seriously
and she thought she was
being like Punk'd because
why would Justin Bieber be calling?
They got the whole thing on the show.
And none of those things I knew about,
people started calling
us and they're like,
you know Drybars, and then
Jimmy Kimmel talks about us
all the time but his wife Molly,
who's now a friend, it wasn't
a friend at the beginning.
She's one of his writers
and she goes to Drybar all the time,
so she would write us
into the Jimmy Kimmel show
and was the same thing I was like,
Jimmy Kimmel is talking about
us, like his late night show.
- What was the single scariest day?
So far?
Last nine years, what
was the single, singular,
toughest day for you personally,
and it might not have been like
some death blow to the company,
but for you personally?
- Yeah, so I think a while ago,
I remember it was still very
new maybe a year or two in.
We were starting to do kinda
promotions with big companies
and we were doing something with HBO.
We do a lot of partnerships
now with big companies
and promoting movies or TV shows,
'cause we have flat-screen
TVs in our shops
that you can watch while
you're getting a blowout.
And we do a lot of partnerships now,
but the very first one we
did was with HBO Girls.
We didn't realize that
HBO was giving away, it
was doing happy hours,
so they were giving away free blowouts
So like the first, I don't know,
hundred people who called,
and it was just one happy hour,
and I think we had at the
time like maybe 20 stores,
and those people who called
first got a free blowout.
We promoted the shit out of
this to our entire audience,
which was like, I don't know,
a couple hundred thousand at that point.
And we were giving out a
couple of hundred blowouts.
Which we disappointed
way more people than we
actually delighted, so
it was such a fuck up,
and we didn't realize it at the time
that we needed to kinda like purse it out,
and not not tell everybody
they can win a blowout,
only a small percentage.
- So the first group was pumped.
- Yeah and then what would happened is
it totally backfired on us because
so many more people couldn't get in it.
- They were like, go fuck yourself
I've been loyal from day one.
- Yeah, and we were like aw shit.
And they were right,
and people were upset,
and I was getting so many mean emails.
We had to categorize them,
and I had to make a
statement to the press, like
I'm so sorry, we messed
up, we didn't realize,
we didn't do this right, which
now we learned our lesson and
we're more careful and methodical.
- Phone numbers we're about
to do questions please.
You got one?
Go ahead.
That makes sense.
- [Alli] Yeah, it was crazy.
- There's really not
much more disappointing
than when you think you're on the verge,
more importantly yes of course,
but when you think you're on the
verge of something super cool
you're like pumped
about it the day before,
you like this is gonna be awesome!
(phone ringing)
And then four seconds in
and you're like, oh shit.
- And then you get your ass
kicked and you're like oh man.
(phone picks up)
- [Nadia] Hello?
- Hey Nadia, you're on the
AskGaryVee Show with Alli Webb.
- [Alli] Hi!
- [Nadia] Oh my gosh, this is crazy!
- It's not that crazy!
You put a phone number into the screen.
- [Alli] Don't you love today?
- So we're here!
- [Nadia] Oh my gosh!
- Where are you from,
what's your question?
- [Nadia] Okay first of all,
- Yes go ahead.
- [Nadia] Gary, I've been following you
for like seven or eight years,
before I even graduated high school,
and you've totally changed
my mindset in so many ways,
and I'm so grateful for that.
Alli, I am a pretty recently
graduated hair stylist,
so I've only been working
for like a year and a half,
- Amazing, congrats!
- [Nadia] Drybar was
my first hair job ever,
and so I worked at the
Louisville Kentucky location.
- [Alli] Amazing!
- So wait wait, Nadia!
Basically Alli and I are
completely responsible
for your life.
- [Nadia] Yeah, honestly, kinda!
It's really crazy.
I'm so grateful to have
been able to work at Drybar
to begin with because it really
set a ground for me as a
stylist because it gave me
comfort and guidance.
- Oh my god you're gonna make me cry!
- [Nadia] I didn't really have to have
that that scary moment of like,
oh my gosh I could really
screw up somebody's hair,
so it was a great foundation
for me as a hair stylist
and I left about, it's probably
been like eight months ago
because I wanted to
pursue hair styling as,
you know like a full-service gig,
so I want to do color,
cut, that whole thing.
Anyway, I have really just been
hesitant to put myself
out there on social media,
which I've done, before I've worked with
brands and I had a blog
and stuff like that.
And I kinda took like a break from that,
but I'm struggling to get back into it.
- Why? What's the true answer?
Is it because you're
starting from a low point
and you don't like the perception
of not having a lot of followers?
Is it you don't feel great about you look?
Is it that you don't know what to say?
- [Alli] You're not
confident in your work?
- What's the real answer?
Let's save time here.
- [Nadia] I think it comes down to,
if I put myself out there
and say somebody comes
to me because they liked
something that I posted
and that if I disappoint
them in the hair salon...
- [Alli] Well, listen, let me tell you
from somebody who's been
doing hair for 20 years
I have disappointed people,
and I have made a lot of people happy.
You will never not disappoint.
There will always be something,
if that doesn't work out.
I mean when I talk to a stylist,
and sometimes it's chemistry.
You know, sometimes,
and this is something I tell
my stylist all the time,
you could do something with someone's hair
that the stylist next you would do the
exact same thing, but they
might like it better from them
because sometimes it's
just a chemistry thing.
They like the way you you touch them,
they might like the way it feels,
they like your personality,
the way you look.
Speaking, going back to judgment.
- I would be the greatest
hairdresser ever or person,
because I would just appease
the person's insecurities,
which is 90% of the reason people go.
- Which is so true, and by the way,
that's such a great
insight that you have that
because the other thing,
it's Natalie right?
- [Nadia] Nadia.
- Nadia, Nadia.
The other thing is just be confident.
People can smell fear on you.
If you're a hair stylist,
people are expecting you to be
really confident in what you're doing
and fake it until you
make it in this industry.
You just have to come at it with this,
you know not being
arrogant, but you have to be
confident in what you're doing.
And you have to understand that
not everyone is gonna love
you, but if you come at it
with this, you think you're great,
you're gonna give them something great,
and if you don't, you don't
and you move on to the next.
- Nadia, I think I'm gonna
build on what Ali said.
Look, I think faking
confidence is very hard.
I really do, but let me give
you something that I think
could really help you.
As to somebody who has an
enormous amount of confidence
who's desperately afraid
of letting anyone down,
I'm gonna say something that
I believe very much and I genuinely
think might work for you.
You do know that the
ability to fix a mistake
is the greatest part of being alive.
- [Alli] It's how you learn.
- So let me explain, I see a great post.
I love the last six things
you did on your Instagram ,
I decide to DM you.
I come to you.
I pay you 98 dollars, 150, whatever.
You do your thing.
I look in the mirror.
I go, what the fuck.
At that moment, you are
in control, not them.
You can give her her money back.
You can give her three hairstyles
for free in perpetuity.
Like, you can do whatever you want.
You're in control.
That may not be what everybody
thinks is the right move,
and I fully understand that.
But most people don't
think most things I do
is the right move.
What Alli thinks is the right move,
based on her reaction, what I think,
this is what's so great.
There is no right, there's
only right for you.
For me, I use money as a way
to subsidize the way I feel.
And so if I don't feel good about it,
I'll give you great example,
back to even the nuance of
me and Alli's body language
up to this answer.
If I cut the hair, Alli
says this is dog shit
and I feel like Alli's
completely out of her mind
and just one of those kind of characters,
I'm not giving her another
cut or her money back.
If Ali says, this is dog shit,
and I say, you know, I was
worried about my grandma's health
today, like I knew I had another
appointment on the back end
and I did rush it a little
bit, and I don't feel great,
my ability to do something about it
right then and there, is real.
You shouldn't worry about
it, because the reality is
you're actually in control.
- [Alli] And I agree with that.
But I do think that as a hairstylist,
when you're first starting
out as a hairstylist,
'cause I've been in her shoes,
it's very jarring and especially
like you were saying about
cutting someone's hair,
making a permanent change;
I was so nervous.
I felt like I was gonna cut people.
When I first got on the floor
when I first started doing hair
I was like nervous I was gonna cut people,
I was so fucking scared.
But you have to.
I understand what you're saying
about not being able to fake confidence
but I think you do have
to dig deep and be like,
I've got this.
If it doesn't work with this woman,
it doesn't work, it's okay.
And it is a learning and
it's not gonna always work,
I don't think every haircut I ever gave
has been the greatest haircut
but I learned from every
single haircut I did.
And I could cover it up
with a great blowout.
- And Nadia I think the other thing
is just understanding you're in control.
I mean this.
Whether these two perspectives
bring you value or not,
it's understanding you're in control.
Like what's gonna happen?
Perspective matters too, I don't know.
You know how scared I am
everyday when a 16 year old
who's getting mentally abused at his home
grabs my arm in the middle of street
and asks me what he
should do with his life?
It sounds super scary to
cut somebody's ear when
you're cutting their hair,
you know what's more scary?
Somebody who's so bought into you
that whatever comes out
of your fucking mouth
is how they're gonna live their life
in a disproportionally scary situation.
The reality is, I know my intent is pure.
I'm doing the best I can.
I try to hedge that, hey
here's my point of view kid.
And I think you're in control.
- [Nadia] Yeah, that's really good advice.
I appreciate that a lot from both of you.
- Alright, good luck.
- [Nadia] Thank you so much, bye.
- [Alli] Bye!
- Yeah let's get another.
Aren't the calls fun?
- [Alli] They're so fun!
Let's do this all day.
- Listen, no joke, it's
funny you said that.
I was thinking the other day,
you know I put out so much content,
I do my thing, but this
is such a rarity for me.
I run a thousand person
company, I'm an operator.
And I always say,
what would happen if I was
just Gary Vee at all times?
And I said man, I would
literally do a morning show
called Tea with Gary Vee,
ironically I'm drinking
tea right the second,
and I would literally do this
from 7:00 a.m. to 11:00.
Everyday!
- That's like my big dream
is having my own show.
- [Phone Assistant] The number
you have dialed is not in-
- That's what I want to do,
that's what I kinda
want my next thing to be
a talk show.
Not a call-in like a TV doctor.
Just putting it out in the universe.
- Back to you and I having two different
angles.
Not points of view, angles.
While Raghav's getting next say,
but don't send it yet,
'cause I have a really funny question.
'Cause what I really enjoyed in that call
was a really important thing which is,
I hear advice from people
that are successful
all the time that would
have never worked for me.
And I give my two cents
on things all the time,
and I can't necessarily give
the right advice for that person.
Give me something that
you thought you heard or read,
or advice your parents
gave as entrepreneurs
that ended up being very different
than what worked for you.
Was there anything?
- I feel like my parents were much more
conservative with their business
and the way they went about things
and their stores were like,
little old lady stores,
and they didn't spend a
lot of money on the decor
and making it look and feel a certain way.
- It was more utilitarian than brand.
- Yeah, it really was, and
I remember when Michael
was trying to get them to go
switch from like literally
cash register to computer,
and they were very resistant on it.
They were kinda set.
- My dad didn't see credit
cards in his liquor store
when I first started working it.
- [Alli] Yeah, I'm sure.
That's how my parents were,
and when we told them we were spending,
half a million dollars in
the build-out of Drybar,
they were like, you're out of your minds.
Like, what are you doing?
Honestly I have to give
my brother a lot of credit
because he knew this award-winning
architect Josh Heitler,
who's built all our stores.
He had that insight, even more than I did
that we have to spend a lot of money
to make it look beautiful,
so people want to be there.
Even though, I wanted to
charge $35 when we started
because I wanted this to
be an affordable luxury
that women of all walks of life could do,
And Michael had the
insight to make it look
really beautiful in high-end
because of that juxtaposition.
And that's also the
beauty of a partnership.
- How much do you think
aspirational affordability
played out your success?
- Tons.
- I couldn't be more passionate
about this subject matter.
You can't have Jay-Z's home,
you can't have Jay-Z's girl,
you can't have Jay-Z's plane,
but you can drink the
champagne that Jay-Z has,
and that's why that works.
- That's exactly was my
thinking on it, was like,
I want this to be something
that you can do if you're not
a celebrity or can afford to have
somebody coming to your house.
- [Gary] In Kentucky, not
just Boca, New York and L.A.
- Yeah, even in L.A.!
Obviously there's a lot of
celebrities in LA where I live
but there's also a lot of college students
and working women who can't
spend $150 or $300 on a blowout
to go to a wedding or on
a date or whatever it is.
- What was the price of the
blowout when you launched?
- $35.
- And now?
- $45.
- And they go $35, $40, $45 or $35 to $45?
- Yeah, it's been a slow ballad.
Which you know, I'd love if
we didn't have to but we do.
(phone ringing)
- That makes a ton of
sense, that's why I asked.
I knew without knowing that's inevitable.
Cost of goods, reality.
- [Alli] Rent. Like real life.
- You can't go out of
business, then it's $0.
- [Alli] Yeah, exactly.
(phone picks up)
- Hello?
- [Virginia] Hello!
- Hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk
you're on with Alli Webb
on the AskGaryVee Show, who's this?
- [Virginia] This is Virginia, hi Gary!
- Hi Virginia!
- [Virginia] Oh my god this was awesome,
how are you doing?
- We're doing super well.
- [Virginia] Awesome!
Good to talk to you, and you too Allie,
it's great to be on.
- Nice to meet you!
- Where are you from and
what's your question?
- [Virginia] I'm from York, Pennsylvania.
I work a full-time day job in an office
also work as pretty much
a full-time dog trainer
I train on evenings and weekends,
give myself Friday evenings
off from dog training,
but you know I'm working
on transitioning out.
Really working as hard as I can
to build up enough capital
so that my husband is
comfortable with me leaving the day job,
'cause it's risky.
It's more risky to him than it is to me,
but it's risky.
And I'm finding very recently that
I'm hitting a lot of burnout.
I hit burnout once every
couple weeks where I'm
just like fucking exhausted
I can't focus at the day job
I don't want to fucking do anything there,
I'm doing dog training stuff on the side,
and I just wanted to hear
both of your opinions
on dealing with burnout when
you know you can't do anything else but
trudge through it.
Like, advice, tips, that kind of thing
and whether either of you
have experienced burnout
and what you guys did for
yourselves to deal with that.
- Where's the passion?
In the dog training, right?
- [Virginia] Oh yeah.
- You know it's funny
that you just said that.
- 'Cause I can totally tell.
- Well she's also not burned out,
she just can't wait to be
full-time dog training.
- Oh, I get it, okay.
I mean here's the thing,
this is like a thing where everyone has
to pay their dues.
I mean shit I did, I'm sure Gary did.
First of all, burnout is real
and yes I've had burnout,
and by the way in another
life I had a dog-walking
business so I am very
passionate about doggies too,
and I have two.
- [Virginia] Nice!
- Who need some training so
if you want to come out to LA.
- [Virginia] I will book a flight!
- But you know, I think burnout is real.
I think I have two
pieces of advice on this.
Are you taking care of
yourself and are you
doing things that make you
feel good and replenished?
For me, I think I was just saying to Gary
that I just started doing
transcendental meditation or
getting a massage or a manicure or maybe
just like taking a nap or going on a hike,
finding something that kinda
refuels your soul, and to know
this is the second part of it,
to know that the day job is temporary,
and it's not gonna always be that way
and you may not be able to see that
right now but you're gonna get to a
point where you're not gonna have to do
the day job because you've been hustling
and hustling and eventually the
pendulum is gonna swing towards the
dog-training business and you'll be able
to quit the day job.
You will as, long as you have the passion
and you're working really hard at it,
and I think the silver lining to get you
through is that you know
there is an end in sight.
- [Virginia] Right, absolutely.
- I also think you have
to figure out where the
burnout's coming from.
I believe that most people get burned out
when they don't feel in control.
Where I want to go with this
question is the following:
I think you're ready to make the move,
I think your husband doesn't want you to.
- [Virginia] That's the
hardest thing is that,
sorry I'm outside,
that's the hardest thing
is that he's very encouraging for me
he wants me to go
full-time, it's financial.
We're kind of in a close
financial straight right now.
- Can you cut back on other things?
- [Virgina] Yeah, and we are.
We definitely are.
- I don't know if you ever have done this,
and I was just telling
a girl friend of mine
who's working on a budget,
there's amazing budget apps
And even now I do this,
where you can basically
put you give yourself a
set amount of money that you can spend
and you cannot go over it,
you put everything you
spend every single day
in that and you basically cut back
on things that you should.
Do not eat dinner out.
Go shopping.
- Do you own your home?
- [Virginia] Yeah, yeah we do.
- You should sell it.
- [Virginia] Yeah, I've thought about
talking to him about that actually.
- Listen to me, and
listen to me real good.
I don't know whether you
should sell your home or not
but here's what I should tell you,
and I believe it more than anything.
Happiness needs to be the ROI of life,
not being able to tell
people you own a home,
nobody gives a shit.
- [Alli] But real estate
is such a good investment.
- Happiness is a better investment.
- I agree, but I mean.
- Let's play here, for example,
real estate is a great investment,
let's play it out.
Right now the real estate
market's very good.
she's burnt out every couple weeks.
She's not making the move
that she already knows she can do.
You can feel it through the
fucking weird phone, right?
- And one of the reasons is
short-term financial stress.
I believe she can sell her home right now
in the height of the market, go rent,
get way happier, happiness
leads to effectiveness,
she starts this dog walking
business that is successful,
and what she has to figure
out on the Delta is,
when the economy gets softer,
is the dog walking business
gonna get hurt more
than the appreciation of the real estate?
And that becomes a very
different kind of question.
But who cares how good your
home returns, if you're unhappy?
Especially when another person
is dictating your decision.
Listen, I understand that's not the most
conventional point of view.
- 'Cause with rent, feels like you're
throwing away money.
- But these are things that
we believed in in the past.
Your parents thought you were an
idiot for $500,000 in aesthetics.
Rent is throwing away money,
is a 1970s point of view.
- It is paying a mortgage
is going towards something.
- Yeah but the biggest asset
in the world is your mindset.
People want to fucking work out
and spend money on meditation
and they don't want to spend
money on their happiness.
- My meditation doesn't cost money.
- Respect. But you see where I'm going?
People are like, hey Gary
you need to take a vacation.
They do escapism.
They fix the sink but
they don't fix the well.
She's dying inside because
she's so ready to run this
business and she has a partner in
life that she clearly respects and loves
enough to take into
consideration but she's ready.
Right? You're ready right?
- [Virginia] Yeah, I have been ready.
- I got good news for you,
you're gonna be burning out more often.
Once you make the mental switch
as a human to be ready for
the next thing, you can't
hold on to the last thing.
- And here's another
little piece of advice,
I mean, to maybe not sell your house.
Maybe you go from the day
job that you hate so much
into something that's more of
a day job in the line of work
that you're in.
Go work at, In L.A. there's
a place called Healthy Spot
that's like a dog place.
Go work at a place that's
at least in the arena
of what you love.
So in the meantime while
you're not ready to make
the full-time leap from your
day office job that you hate,
go into a job that you kind of like
that has to do with dogs
can kind of fuel your your passion
but you're not 100%
out of a second income.
- [Virginia] Right, right.
I've thought about that too, for sure.
- So like talk to me,
I'm really interested
in this subject matter
I'm not letting you go just yet.
- [Virginia] You've got it.
- Answer some questions for me,
your husband's working
and contributing as well?
- [Virginia] Yeah.
- [Alli] Can you rent
a room in your house?
- How many you extra rooms in your house
do you have that you
guys don't really use?
- [Virginia] Honestly, none.
We have a really small ass house.
- No, I really appreciate that.
- Are you marketing your
dog training business?
Can that get to the next level?
- [Virginia] Yeah, I
definitely need to start
investing in more marketing.
Like I started just by making a profile on
Thumbtack.com, and I've
been living off of that.
But I have my website up and running,
I've been getting a lot of organic reach
on the website without
even putting any money
into Google ads or Facebook Ads yet.
- What about Instagram?
- [Virginia] I have an Instagram page,
but I haven't been doing
anything with that yet either.
I really want you to go ahead into that.
- And like, cute pictures of dogs,
there's nothing that gets more attention
than really cute fucking pictures of dogs,
I mean am I right?
Everybody in this room
is shaking their head.
It's such a slam dunk when you have cute
pictures of dogs,
especially if you're like,
I can make your dog stop
peeing on the floor.
- When you're burned out, what's going on?
Is it happening out of
actual physical exhaustion
or is it more, it's Wednesday,
and you're going into the next
eight hours and you hate
that you're doing that.
- [Virginia] Yes. Like every couple weeks
I just get physically exhausted,
and then every once in a while
it's mental exhaustion too.
- Listen, I think Alli's
drilling these practical advices,
I'm a big fan of getting a
different job that pays you
less than the thing you like.
- Just as a bridge.
- No, I think it's awesome.
I'm just also a pretty
big fan of selling homes.
- [Alli] I don't know if I agree
with the selling your house.
- It doesn't work for everybody.
- 'Cause I think you could probably find
something else that you
love in the dog world.
- Alli you know what's really interesting?
A lot of the Silicon Valley
people that made a ton of money
in the last wave of
other of all this choice
never owned a home, and continue not to.
I'm really serious about this,
I think owning a home
and going to college,
in 25 to 40 years is gonna
look more like women should stay home
and raise families did 30
years ago, 50 years ago.
I'm not kidding.
- Really?
- I really do.
- [Alli] Why?
- Because I think the
practicality around them
was more realistic for the
world we lived in in the past.
- But if you own a home,
you're putting money towards
something that you own.
If you're renting something,
you're putting money
that you toward something
that you don't get back.
- But when you take into
account people not knowing how
to put down deposits, which may be the
answer to this question.
- [Alli] You have to do it smart.
- But that's not what
actually manifests, right?
And so to me, when you take three
hundred thousand or fifty thousand or
ten thousand dollars out of your account
and you add up mortgage, to me,
for what? For what?
Okay, so you have an asset,
you're making an assumption that the
appreciation of that is going to turn
into something that you what?
You sell and then move to Florida?
- But I don't think it
has to be a huge gain.
If you can gain 50 grand or 100 grand
or whatever it is from
selling your house to
upgrading a little.
- Is that 50 grand or 100 grand worth
living another four and a half
years in an unhappy state?
- I think there's other
things she can be doing.
She's fucking answering
questions that I don't like.
She has no extra rooms,
her husband working and contributing.
- [Alli] She can get a different day job.
She hasn't given us a
whole lot of other things.
- And she's got the support
of her husband who wants her
to pursue this full-time.
I think there's a way for her to do it.
- How how well is the dog business doing?
- [Virginia] Fairly well.
I'm booked out for the next
two weeks with appointments.
I have co-consults and consults coming in.
- Let me ask you a question.
Without being delirious,
and your best guess
how much do you think
you could make a year
if you went full-time?
Just your best guess, be
relatively conservative,
don't be emotionally excited.
Try to really give me an answer here.
What do you think?
- [Virginia] Guaranteed
I could make as much
as I'm making it the day job,
probably another 20 grand more
than that so like 60 grand.
- So now what's happening with you
is the debate that Alli and I are having,
in a great way, which is the thing that
drives me like you cannot imagine.
Which is perception versus reality.
- Just do it!
- You are taking on your husband's
lack of interest in risk and making it
your own in a world where if you do not
quit your job tomorrow, I'm pissed.
- Yes quit your job!
You will have such a
short amount of downtime
prepare for that time, get ready,
make sure you guys don't
spend any money that
you absolutely don't have to
spend even if it takes you,
I think maybe not tomorrow,
if you takes you a month
to get your ducks in a row
so you can then say,
okay I'm gonna quit.
I'm gonna give myself
a month to build up my
business and then you're done.
- You mean the business that
pays you as much as the
fucking job you have
that you that makes you hate,
that makes you have mental burnout?
- This is like entrepreneurialship 101.
This is the problem honestly,
and I don't know if you agree Gary,
that most entrepreneurs have.
They are so afraid to leave their jobs
and to pursue their passion,
usually because of money.
Which is why either now
or maybe you're so far gone
that you're so unhappy,
but to all entrepreneurs
out there listening,
if you have if you have intent and hope
to eventually start your own business,
start putting money aside in a secret
account that you cannot touch now.
So once you're really
ready to pursue that,
you have a cushion.
I feel like so many people I talk to,
they're not set up to
start their business,
and they get to the
point they're burned out.
- And their answer is to raise capital,
not build something practical.
- Get yourself to position,
or if there's your mate
or parents or somebody who can give you
that buffer, that cushion so
then you can go and do it.
You have to just get
yourself prepared to it,
sometimes that takes a year of planning.
- Virginia, who's in
your world saying jump
and who's in your world saying don't jump?
- [Virginia] My husband
saying jump in a little while.
- How long has he been saying that?
- [Virginia] Not that long
because I haven't really
been gung-ho about going full-time.
I've been saying, oh next year I'll do it.
Last year I was saying
next year's the year,
and now that I'm here I'm
like, okay by the end of the
summer and he's going, duh
if you're ready then okay,
by the end of the summer.
- Listen, life is short my friend.
Life is too short to be doing something
that you're not happy in.
- Alli's tune has changed,
because what I love about Alli
gathering here...
- I still don't want
her to sell her house.
- That's fine and I respect
the shit outta that.
And I'll tell you why,
you don't want her to sell
her house because your filter is proper,
it's very practical.
Everything that's come
out of your mouth has been
so disproportionately practical,
the only difference between
you and I on this issue,
is I have a perspective today
that believes selling a home
is a practical behavior, and you don't.
And that's okay,
but everything you've
been saying is practical.
The reason Alli's changing her tune to
go now and life is short,
is you've given her the
data and the information,
to know this transition is practical.
I've got news for you by the way.
By doing this for a long time,
you're going to do 25 to 50
percent better than you think.
Just so you know real quick,
when you call back in a year,
you're gonna make fifty
percent more than your job,
because of everything I've
heard in the last 15 minutes.
- And by the way, I
think you called in today
because you wanted us
to tell you to do it.
- Hundred percent.
- And we're telling you to do it.
Quit your job, pursue your dream.
- Get your husband on
the phone, three way.
What's his name?
Virginia what's your husband's name?
- [Virginia] He's in really
big board meeting actually
Gary, I don't think he
can get on the phone.
- What's his name?
- [Virginia] Jake.
- I want you, me and Jake on
a phone in the next 24 hours,
I want you to email Gary@vaynermedia.com,
I want me, you and Jake.
- Damn I'm gonna miss the call!
- Allie you can be part of it!
four-way call, that new
FaceTime group shit.
Listen to me, and listen to me good.
You need to move fast.
- I mean the world can end next week!
- And there's no doubt
that this is what you should be doing.
- [Virginia] Yeah, there really isn't.
- By the way, the reason
you've been recently
burnt out more, is because you switched.
You switched!
Your switch went off, and
now it's all terrible.
It's why in fourth grade I quit school.
I switched in 4th grade.
In 4th grade I switched from,
school is the way out, school is good,
school will help me,
to oh fuck school will not help me,
school is not the way out.
And I switched,
dramatically earlier than most people,
but this is when you switch
when you're in a relationship.
One week earlier, you're in love.
We're gonna get married, life is amazing,
and then something happens and you switch.
And then three months
later people break up.
You know that your switch switched.
And now you're unhappy, and by the way,
you're gonna get
systematically more unhappy.
- Yep. There's only one
way to go from here.
- Virginia you switched.
- [Alli] Virginia do it!
- [Virginia] All right!
Thank you guys so much,
I appreciate it so much,
Gary and Allie, I really do.
- Good luck.
And Virginia, don't take the high of this
17 minute 33 second call,
you need this tonight
when you talk to Jake,
you need this tomorrow,
do not do what everybody does,
which you're hyped is fuck now, and your
head's like, yep Monday
or a month from now.
The reason I want you to go tomorrow
and not 30 days from now is
I'm worried about the
vulnerability of 30 days
from now actually becomes September,
the day after Labor Day which then
actually becomes Christmas,
then something weird happens and all of
a sudden, fucking fuck.
Virginia. Fucking fuck, Virginia.
- And meanwhile I asked if
I could curse on this show.
- Like fucking quit tomorrow, let's go.
- [Alli] I'm with you.
- If you quit tomorrow
I'll make you promise.
If you quit tomorrow, I will personally,
I never do this, I will
personally heavily shout out
your business on social
to get you 50 clients
you would have never had.
- [Alli] I will too.
- Alli will too!
But you must quit tomorrow!
And you have to prove it to me.
- [Alli] You're so intense!
You want her to sell her
house and quit her job.
- I do.
- You know what, you
can come live with Gary.
- You sure can 'cause I'm
fucking about happiness here.
- [Virginia] Yeah, you guys
rock, thank you so much.
- What's gonna happen tomorrow?
- [Alli] She's gonna quit
her job and sell her house.
- [Virginia] I'm fucking quitting man.
- Virginia are you are
you gonna quit tomorrow?
- [Virginia] Yeah.
- You swear?
No, for real for real.
Don't fuck with me 'cause
my emotions get crazy.
- [Virginia] For real Gary.
- 'Cause you're ready, right?
- [Virginia] I am.
- You quit six weeks ago.
13 weeks ago.
Now you're just going
through negative motions.
- [Virginia] Yeah, I am.
- I know. All right, I love you.
- This is so fun good.
Let's do this all day.
- [Virginia] Love you both too.
- [Alli] Good luck!
- Well listen, don't say it too much
because we're gonna get bombarded
by TV producers being like, you two!
- We should have a show!
- All right I gotta get you out of here.
Thank you; question of the day.
You get to ask it.
Every time a guest is on here
they get to ask the question of the day.
Now, be selfish or curious here.
You're gonna thousands
of answers on social so,
what question do you
want to ask the masses?
Whether you want to be very
directly to your business,
something macro, wherever you want to go,
this is your opportunity but the question
of the day from Alli.
- What's your age demo, do you know?
- Yeah.
It's very heavy 17 to 35 year old male.
- I never get male demo.
- That's 65%, then 35% is
like 27 to 49 year-old female.
- I knew about this question so I was
thinking about it all day.
I'm kind of curious, in today's society,
with social media and everything
what do you care about
the most in the world?
Is it your families?
Is it your job?
I'm just so curious, what
is driving people today.
Before we go off the air,
a girl in my office her
name is Stacy Levine,
she's my sweet Stacy,
she's my social media,
I don't know what her
actual title is, shit,
Stacy I love you, she's so
near and dear to my heart,
she's obsessed with you!
And I told her that I would
give you her a shout-out,
and you would give her a shout-out!
- Stacy I love you!
Where is she is she in L.A.?
- Yeah she's in California.
- I hope I get to meet you Stacy.
Thank you so much for the love,
thanks for watching.
- And thank you for having
me this is so, so fun!
You guys are all awesome, this is so cool.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them
On this episode rock star
entrepreneur Alli Webb stops by.
Awesome!